hallo mein name ist luca meine lieben
freunde vor einigen tagen habe ich
bereits auf die erste episode der neuen
prosieben tv show namens beauty ende
nerd reagiert in der show geht es darum
dass sieben komplette beauty mädels auf
7 kompletten teams treffen die müssen
paare bild und das kann dass am ende die
meisten challenges meistern und am ende
einfach noch übrig ist gewinnt 50.000
euro und wir schauen jetzt dort weiter
wo die sich jetzt zum ersten mal sehen
es wirkte so als wenn niemand so richtig
interessiert wäre und ich habe nur noch
mal noch mal einen blick geworfen
aber noch mal ein blick geworfen dann
dachte ich na gut dann halt nicht der
elia oder wieder da ist der findet wohl
nicht so gut anschluss wieder zurückgeht
oder was und jetzt der nächste also hier
übrigens das sind die sieben beauty
mädels und das sind die sieben nerd
jungs 8 und ihre zeit
er ist zurückgekommen das fällt mir das
auch passiert ja mit deinen ohren auf
gar keinen fall bruder schmerzt schon so
ein bisschen dann eine schöne stelle für
den kollegen lieber wenn zehn jahren
schuf angst haben merkt man auch schon
das ja dann deutlich kraft weiter mit
möchtegern priesters wenn die fast so
frauen wie wird es richtig ist
der fast so frauen wie gottesfürchtig es
aber wert hängt sich diese jobs aus ob
er sich erfüllt hängt davon ab ob die
geologie landen kann
das will ja gespannt ach gott die decke
so oder so ob mutis mein name ist wenn
und gottes mein ständiger begleiter und
euch ist bereit mit mir diesen weg zu
gehen
ich bin gespannt ob er auf anklang
finden wird
da hat auch jemand mit einem
laserschwert draußen ein
ich bin laser luca halten wollte das war
wirklich so ein verwirrender augenblick
bin auch gespannt was die da jetzt
immerhin tim zieht sven hin kind sieht
so sven hin schon etwas schockiert ich
auch
er ist jedoch gerade meinte sie erwartet
einen typen mit laserschwert nicht mit
jesus latschen wo hast du dich für mich
entschieden das erste glaube und gott
was ganz neues in welchen ich fand es
voll interessant gerade was sie denkt
halt so gegensätzlich das 70 an
auch heftig dass so glaube und gott so
das ist was ganz neues für mich und das
fand ich gerade irgendwie interessant
okay
nein das ist doch nicht sein ernst und
ich bin gespannt ob der das ist der typ
mit seinem komischen elf toren ich bin
gespannt ob halo ohne seine band social
verlassen nicht dass sein handy geht
auch klar von der qualität mit ihr hat
er spielt hat wirklich
ich dachte ich hatte ja immer so gemacht
und haben das irgendwie drüber gelegt
aber dann spielt wirklich trompete meine
couch hier verbringe ich meine freizeit
okay dann habe ich zunächst mal ist wenn
man meine mom nicht mit
[Musik]
jedem das seine
doch nicht dein ernst oder in ganz
netter kerl wird extrem freundlich und
vor allem richtig liebevoll aber
ich kann mir auch nicht vorstellen dass
er da jetzt direkt mädel finden wird ich
glaube kümmert das schon eine ganz gute
wahl getroffen mit dem sven ich hatte
bisher immer nur mit digitalen
schönheiten zu tun welche von euch
möchte meine reale prinzessin sein
ach gottchen digital inwiefern
videospieler
i
elias ich drücke ihr alle daumen die ich
habe was soll das denn mit den orden aus
sich fühlst du dich wie so ein wohn oder
1 9
genau ein hörer sind ja und hier ist
auch für die ordnung also und kann elf
ja das ist richtig ich bin helfer steht
für mich aber eigentlich symbolische
mehr oder weniger für mein
hauptaugenmerk dass videospiele betrifft
er spielt also elfen videospieler ich
habe halt mein leben lang nur gta fifa
und minecraft gespielt und da kommen
keine elfen drin vor
ja genau
ich bin gespannt wer sich da entscheidet
lieber angenehm ist jetzt tatsächlich so
und interessante sich keine für sich
entscheiden möchte hast du jetzt
irgendwas falsch gemacht er hätte mir
schon ein bisschen leid ne also ich
meine ich kann irgendwo die beauty
mädels auf der einen seite verstehen die
stehen halt eher auf beauty die jungs
dann wahrscheinlich und er ist halt kein
blutjunge in die iss muss man ganz klar
leider so sagen obwohl und so netter
mensch bist du wirkst du mir das so
drastisch wenn ich mal muse habt dann
wenn ich mir hat die muße hat die muse
dann mache ich auch paar wochen haben
stück war morgens training boxtraining
und er macht boxtraining ich bin die
j clin ja mit der musik passt eigentlich
sängerin bin ein ständchen zusammen
singen und schlagersternchen lager
stehen sich zum duett annabelle
für mich ist eine jacqueline lasst uns
leben wir wollen was erleben vorwärts
herz lacht
[Musik]
wer so schlecht
da kannst du echte karriere einschlagen
ich denke was mit meinem bett schlafen
geht stellt dem damit diese uhren oder
was auch ja mit der trompete auch so
richtige gaudi oder haltung spricht muss
mit dem in meinem bett schlafen da
vergeht mir alles mit der trompete oder
arm etwas home ein konto mit den ohren
zeichne programmier schreibe bücher oder
gegen rafinha kann sogar fettes das
kicken
[Musik]
hallo hallo beauties hallo ich bin der
ja
genau
gute unterhaltung da können wir ja
wiederholen das ist sportlich ja ich
trainiere auch so seit kurzem so jeden
tag liegestützen hier schnell
das fällt ja nicht gedacht dass er so
fix geht bzw
wieso hast du dich für mich entschieden
was du kannst anfang ein bisschen ladies
first perfekte aussage den zusammenhang
also ich denke wenn du mich nimmt dass
wir das durch die mir da sagst du das
luft gas darauf hin dass wir das
schaffen und dass man sich vielleicht
noch ein bisschen schmieden könnte bis
hin zu offener wird
ich denke dass frische
gut haben wir auch unser nächstes
mädchen am start arbeiten könnte ich sag
mal du sitzt du gedeihen und da wird das
machen glauben
wer kennt es nicht wenn man seinen
freund wie ein hund behandelt
halb superman super julien hochgefühl
das super und so schauen wo das okay
hoffentlich werden es nicht als geklaut
weil superman 3 ich bin gespannt sie
geht ich glaube der erste dakar bekommen
denken sie jetzt auch so gut bin nicht
so schlimm da kam superman und er waren
danach das ist irgendwie so offen locker
flockig so wie ich aus der hose raus ich
dachte dadurch dass ich meine videos
nicht mehr im stehen aufnehmen sondern
besitzen zwinge ich mich am schreibtisch
sitzen zu bleiben aber nein
ich rolle dann einfach weg aus dem bauch
raus kommt die klar anders wenn ich
meine heutige reaction auf beauty endet
jetzt allerdings auch beenden wenn der
liebe freunde wenn es euch gefallen hat
darf gerne einen daumen hoch unter dem
video das schafft mir 50.000 like ist
beim mega krass und wird mit zeigen ja
ihr habt doch bock dass sich ein drittes
mal darauf reagiere
und ich meine es ist so witzig es ist so
unterhaltsam dieser serie sie hat so
auch in sehr hohen kultfaktor aber
gerade das macht das ganze auch so
lustig übrigens heute abend um 20 15 uhr
neue folge patienten auf prosieben
aber die folge auf die ich heute
reagiert auch unten in der beschreibung
verlinkt und jetzt befinden uns auch
schon in der endart meine lieben freunde
werden noch kein abonnent von meinem
kanal sei dann klickt hier oben auf den
smiley darauf hatte ich verpasse nämlich
keine videos mehr es ist kostenlos und
wenn dann klickt auf die glocke
denn dann bekommt er eine
benachrichtigung sobald ich ein neues
video hochladen können direkt wird dabei
sein und hier ist nach einer video
verlinkt nämlich meine erste reaktion
auf julian genannt